[Musique]
maroni je vais te faire découvrir un
super dispositif le chèque marmaille un
joli coup de pouce pour les parents
justement je suis sur place pour
rencontrer une maman qui en a bénéficié
elle va tout nous expliquer tu vas voir
vous aussi le shaq marmaille ça vous
intéresse alors suivez-moi
[Musique]
c'est ici à sainte clotilde que prisca
cook ans vit avec ses trois enfants
cette mère célibataire peut travailler
en toute sérénité grâce au chèque
marmailles du département avec ce
soutien financier son petit dernier peut
aller à la crèche pendant que maman
travaille allez on va tout de suite la
rejoindre
prisca merci de nous accueillir
aujourd'hui avec les ja alors dit nous
concrètement à quoi te sert le shaq marc
by marc échec marmaille ça me permet d
aider à payer la facture de crèche sans
trop dépenser financièrement ou même
voir parfois pas du tout et comment est
ce que ça fonctionne cantonné - la
fameuse chanson je reçois un chéquier du
lis tu dises tous les mois pour payer
cette fameuse facture de crèches et ce
chaque marmaille il a aidé
professionnellement de quelle manière
oui mais beaucoup aidé
professionnellement j'étais dans la
restauration autrefois à l'effet que je
peux faire garder mon enfant sans trop
dépenser
faire une formation justement par
rapport à ça et dont je travaillais
alors d'aujourd'hui en tant que head à
domicile pour les personnes âgées
handicapées et ce chèque marmol dure
combien de temps j'ai appris que et peut
être utilisé jusqu'à là les six ans une
bonne nouvelle alors très bonnes veines
merci en tout cas puisqu'en merci à vous
[Musique]
grâce au chèque marmaille des parents
comme prisca peuvent inscrire leur
enfant à la crèche ou avec une
assistante maternelle depuis 2013 le
département permet aux familles modestes
de faire garder leur marmaille à prix
réduit et vous allez l'entendre le
dispositif est également prévu pour les
enfants porteurs de handicap
bonjour docteur nous sommes dans une
magnifique crèche de saint denis qui
utilisent le chèque marmaille alors
dites nous comment ça marche le chèque
marmaille est un dispositif du conseil
départemental il vise à soutenir les
parents pour les inscrire dans un mode
d'accueil du jeune enfant cela peut être
en crèche avec un montant allant jusqu'à
840 euros par an ou chez une assistante
maternelle agréée du dispositif jusqu'à
1200 euros par an et comment ce que des
parents peuvent bénéficier de ce choc
marmagne il s'agit de remplir un
formulaire et de le retourner au conseil
départemental qui peut être téléchargé
sur le site il dit penser départementale
récupérer dans un centre de pmi ou bien
les parents peuvent aller directement à
la cellule cheikh mahmoud sur saint
denis alors vous avez également pensé
aux parents d'enfants en situation de
handicap de quelle façon les enfants
porteurs de handicap qui est un projet
d'accueil individualisé au sein d'une de
ces structures peuvent bénéficier du
chèque marmaille avec un montant allant
jusqu'à 250 euros par mois et sans
limite celle du quotient familial merci
docteur merci
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'information contacter la direction
enfance famille services ressources
cellule cheikh marmaille par téléphone
au 02 62 90 07 47 ou sur le site
internet
www.cgi.com au point fr le département
des générations c'est fini si vous
souhaitez revoir cet épisode ainsi que
les précédents rendez vous sur nos sites
et nos réseaux sociaux quant à moi je
vous retrouve très vite pour un nouvel
épisode à bientôt
[Musique]
salut alexandre bonjour maroni je veux
aujourd'hui les combats vacances à saint
gilles c'est là que les aidants
familiaux peuvent venir se détendre et
ici maintenant a bien besoin ça c'est
sûr et comment se déroulent ces moments
de repos et ben justement mais sarah
découvre tout ça les sahwa
[Musique]